naja was geht hier ist euer max und ich
bin immer noch im gang mit shirt und
kurz nach dem aufstehen aber die letzten
folgen waren so so intense und haben so
viel spaß gemacht dass sie einfach nicht
aufhören möchte jetzt hier aufzunehmen
der verbrauch auf dem server es geht für
mich jetzt noch zu klären mit mir selbst
möchte ich das hier noch beenden möchte
ich den dungeon fertig werden
oder log ich mich lieber aus weil das
heißt ich mich lieber aus oder habe ich
lieber ab so ich hab jetzt schon vier
kisten geöffnet insgesamt wie ich glaube
es die ja wie ich gesagt hat es gibt
acht insgesamt und ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher ob ich das wirklich
riskieren möchte hier noch mal abzuhauen
protection vier der helm ist sogar
lustiger weise das was als erstes kaputt
zu gehen droht man kann hier auch mal
anziehen weil es gibt ja gar kein set
buß dass das ganze paket hier so und ich
will nicht ganz riskieren dass hier
irgendwie was drunter ist was ich nicht
einschätzen kann
sonst würde ich mich ja noch ein runter
bahn okay so konnte er so wenn man das
hier erst mal alles erledigt hat dann
dürfte draußen wieder so einigermaßen
reinen luft sein aber es ist da jetzt
einfach zuviel gespannt in der kurzen
zeit wo ich da draußen herum gelaufen
bin und mir alles ja ein bisschen
bisschen sehr ruhig zugegeben angeschaut
hab letzte letzte folge was hier alles
für zeugs bond ist unglaublich ich
sollte auf jeden fall darauf achten dass
mir das hier so ein bisschen als
rückzugsort bleibt so ich kann wie das
bonner abbauen auch es um eine kritik
ist weg
das den einfach so fielen aber die
vanilla mops machen eine mir so eine
panik in diesem dungeon sicher nicht
jetzt und damit 3 wobei dass das kind
ein glaube ich auch nicht komplett aber
das ist eine der sachen wo ich jetzt
weniger bereit wäre ein risiko
einzugehen was mir schon alles angeguckt
hat und was nicht
so aber auf jeden fall auch für das
level farm ist dass sie einfach ist
einfach göttlich so tempel koller ich
glaube den nehmen wir uns mal mit hier
so den den tempel du zu rufen ist jetzt
auch nicht falsch das ist ja glaube ich
etwas später ein ein amboss wie man sich
vor knüpfen kann
immer wieder hören dann machen wir das
hier ganz in ruhe wird cat worten zu
sagen komm papa und dann würde ich auch
schon echt ganz zurückgetreten bin
nächste folge dermaßen bereit in
dermaßen breit in der nächsten folge mit
meiner blatt magic weiterzumachen
wir haben es nicht geschafft uns jetzt
selbst gerät wieder
dann baue ich mich mal die bei ein bis
der effekt weg ist da macht man auf
jeden fall nichts falsch mit hier nicht
so viele herzen verloren jetzt beim
letzten mal hatte das mittelding michael
dann doch ein bisschen in gefahr
gebracht
okay da war ich schon dran
unnötig ist noch mal rein zu gucken aber
besser ist irgendwas liegen zu lassen
so seht ihr das wichtig dem weg combo
hier war ich auch schon dran
die ganzen engelswies ihr vorhin habe
ich die so gesucht die emmerick erst
jetzt nächste alle nicht mit ein
bisschen bisschen undankbar okay sagt
freuen hab ich dir gesucht meiner mutter
halt so in den in den letzten folgen
sondern erst mal was essen und dann
denkmal streifen auch schon wieder den
rückweg an ihre bonn ist etwas habe ich
zum glück was habe ich eigentlich führen
fünf fällen glück der typ gibt mir schon
wieder die die stärke dieses ehre
bonding das anscheinend irgendwie einen
gott für mich ist natürlich nur der
einzig wahre gott was ihr wisst ihr
bescheid
also wenn du das für star wars kollege
geht mir gern
wann immer du irgendwie was übrig hast
von irgendwelchen ressourcen
ich bin hier immer sehr dankbar
soja wird würde ich würde sagen wir
stellen unser glück muss weiter auf die
probe und verwiesen uns
aus diesem dungeon wir haben wir uns
jetzt wie sondern anders wie soll es
anders sagen wir uns jetzt durchaus hold
war die uns glück gebracht hat so
einfach stur nach oben bauen was anderes
möchte ich nicht riskieren so und dann
haben wir auch noch den den anti atlas
dabei aber uns den weg nach hause leiten
wird
ja ist doch alles schon schon sehr
harmonisch und schön
ich bin aber nur happy dass es so gut
lief ist ich bin auf jeden fall auch im
dungeon bin ich jetzt gar nicht so viel
gelaufen
also es ist nicht so als würde ich das
würde ich mich da in übertriebene
klassieren für märz 891 wird sein vater
vielleicht einfach mal zu dungeon und
dungeons habe ich erst mal genug das
interessiert mich glaube ich auch dass
wir wahrscheinlich rubin sein und dann
platziert patrick einfach mal als
geschenk zurück quasi hier den ganzen
abend ist denn ich habe in einer kiste
in der stadt weil es hat er sich
verbessert dass ich euch verdient der
patriot also ohne patrick werden wir
überhaupt nicht imstande gewesen zu sein
ja ich glaube es ist eigentlich so gut
13 taktisch jetzt ein bisschen sehr
übertrieben dass wegzuwerfen deshalb
unsere letzte fackel nehmen wir uns auf
jeden fall auch mal mit wo ist denn auch
wenn die da liegt leuchtet es sogar hat
den den shining powers dauern also diese
beiden star beiden steine und hier liegt
sogar noch so ein ding sind die
vielleicht doch nicht so selten ich mir
dachte gestern in castoren also
irgendwie jede menge power stones haben
wir hier
ja ab nach oben ab nach oben vielleicht
ist ja oh oh ich hab eine spitzhacke was
mache ich auch immer für sachen leute
ich hoffe immer dass ich hier im ganzen
bisschen holz finde das muss ich dann
den ganzen weg wählen aber ohne sich in
der wand einzubauen ist es verrückt vor
es ist verrückt diesen diesem ort vor
allem ein trick sein wird hier war ich
doch sogar schon
ich muss den weg hoch irgendwie wieder
finden das sieht gut aus auch ich will
keinen tricks der leute alles bloß
keinen schrägster okay gut das war gut
was wir gerade gesehen haben ach so ich
habe ja kein spielzeug mehr ich hab ja
schon ganz einfach blind auch da geht es
gar nicht hoch oder wie wir müssen den
weg hoch finden ich habe keine
spitzhacke es ist so verrückt wir töten
einfach ab so auch ab sofort mops die
eine spitzhacke in der hand haben
spitzhacken sind unser neue unsere neuen
diaz wir brauchen sie oder holz holz
wäre auch nicht falsch da ist der
aufgang und ich muss mich jetzt habe ich
wirklich befürchte ich mit der hand
hierdurch bauen das sich zum ausgang
kommen leute tut mir den gefallen und
vergesst niemals irgendwo hin
da hätte ich mir schon denken können
dass er selber fuß raus kommt vergesst
niemals irgendwo in holz mitzunehmen
wenn ihr minecraft spielt ich vergesse
immer wieder in die höhlen holz
mitzunehmen bzw ich hatte ja sogar ein
bisschen was dabei aber das ginge dann
auch direkt wieder für für was anderes
drauf für für fackeln also wirklich
nimmt immer holz mit egal was passiert
warum bauen geht es die fackel vor allem
aus und irgendwie geupdatet in meiner
hand oder so was weiß ich jetzt nicht
genau was der grund dafür ist weiß nur
dass ich hier schnellstmöglich und auch
möglichst sicher raus möchte um jeden
preis faces runner erhöhen sogar mein
main hunter level ein bisschen
mattersburger leggins ja weiß nämlich
die nehmen sollte kartoffel pedro
es gibt vieles was ich hier im inventar
hab was sie einfach nicht so dichte was
man eigentlich sie wegschmeißen könnte
auch danke baby zu haben
zum glück richtig getötet das werk jetzt
weg strings das sind alles sachen die
eigentlich voll stressig zu farben sind
aber die akut dieser bbc hat uns gerade
sozusagen den arsch gerettet
gibt es noch etwas drin looki looki ja
dann ab nach oben baby zum ich danke dir
danke vielmals dass uns das möglich
gemacht hast glaube nicht dass es seine
absicht war baby zum ist ja eigentlich
eher nicht so lieb sind dumme fehler
dumme fehler ja
so und jetzt nach oben man verliert
echtzeit durch solche dummheiten die
zeit ist wirklich wertvoll
also da muss ich sagen bin ich ein
bisschen sauer auf mich selbst dass ich
das hier ist mal wieder vergessen
solche sachen mitzunehmen das wird mich
jetzt die ganze zeit stören das weiß
jetzt schon deshalb spricht in seiner
zur seite da rein in gold nugget
so werde ich bleiben darf sich ruhig
bleiben die fackel so hoch mit dir so
elf minuten 41
wenn wir noch recht engen nach oben
gekommen dann schaffen wir es vermutlich
in die stadt zurück und diesmal
erstmalig mit irgendwas also ich habe
ich das gefühl dass er das erste mal
selbst was verdient haben dass wir uns
das erste mal wirklich ja was geschafft
habe bisher war es immer
danke danke dem team aber blatt magic
anwalt gemacht so und andere sind halt
einfach durchgezogen somit mit anderen
sachen
bisher hat ml die fackel die fackel
kriegen hdd control
oder ist da ist die oberfläche gut es
ist mitten in der nacht leute ihr wisst
ja wie ich zur nacht stehen in dem map
pack oder wie wahrscheinlich jeder hin
zur nacht steht in dem aspekt nicht so
super cool und direkt vor der tür wieder
wieder rausgekommen
da hatte ich jetzt die die kiste mit dem
portal stein platziert die nehme ich
jetzt aber direkt wieder mit weil ich
mein ich schaff's ja auch ganz
offensichtlich in dieser folge wieder
zurück
und was weiß lass ich mal hier spinnen
augen solche sachen die man halt nicht
unbedingt brauchen wird und falls man
sie dann doch braucht kann einfach
zurückkehren zu sich holen so und anti
atlas sag mir wohin der weg führt alles
klar leute ich freue mich wirklich nach
nach diesem action reichen folgen zurück
nach hause zu kehren
einstein reste server sehr gut ich freue
mich sehr zurück zurückzukehren
mit vollen taschen keine essens probleme
mehr und die perfekten voraussetzungen
für spannende nicht zu folgen
wir werden vielleicht schaffe ich das
sogar noch diese folge dass wir fliegen
das wäre natürlich der wahnsinn ach da
kann ich gerade auf dem feld mitnehmen
also irgendwie karotten feld oder so was
wenn die einst haben dass wir auch nicht
von der hand zu weisen für unsere stadt
karotten wo denn wo den wurde
respekt aber an diejenigen die in den
ersten folgen schon die dungeons geklärt
haben also das war wirklich intense
wobei die haben es ja meistens zu zweit
gemacht die dann schließlich vorgeknöpft
aber trotzdem muss ich sagen hut ab
also ich fand schon extrem extrem
spannend jetzt die tanten sich
vorzunehmen derzeit klappt muss ich mich
jetzt nicht mit rumschlagen wortwörtlich
rumschlagen überhaupt aber es ist
wirklich geschafft
ich hätte vor ein echt today the big day
das finde ich schön
es freut mich dass das spiel das auch so
sieht
ok hinten giant hat mich nicht
hochwerfen leute ich glaube das wäre das
problem der hat wahrscheinlich so
richtig niedrige leben aber wenn ein
hoch wirft ist er gefährlich was hat er
gehabt
holz aber nur holz 240 euro
dieses spiel muss man nicht immer
verstehen
ich dachte mir ich hab mich so vollen in
gefahr begeben diesen riesen anzugreifen
gut ich konnte ja auf long range einiges
machen ja nur getraut weil er so wenig
leben hatte aber ja wir haben es jetzt
irgendwie doch geschafft ohne probleme
hey lass mich in ruhe du kleiner [ __ ]
bisschen händler
tut mir leid kollege ich lass dich nicht
lächerlich was kann es mir anbieten
ok empfiehlt langsam and void kann man
auch gute sachen greifen also klappt act
19 schwerter und wir haben ja auch
direkt bei uns vor der tür so ein ding
kollege dass mir wo ich will einfach du
gehst da erst mal hin
damals verstanden hätte schon wieder in
remsede drobny was ist das hier ist
nicht wissen ich werde einfach
eigentlich aber nur schnell einbauen
du bleibst erstmal drin so cordes
screenshot noch kurz kollege als wir die
schnauze halten
all dies nur kurz zu den schotten falls
das irgendjemand braucht wie ich gehe
dann immer lieber auf nummer sicher
weil diese ganzen trader und sowas sind
ja eigentlich ganz cool
also man kann dadurch gute sachen
kriegen also haben wir den see tempel
und da gibts halt mord in die kannst du
auf level 30 angreifen
und wenn du die dann erledigt trägst du
diese entlang sie verheißen auch ein
verweis und die sind eigentlich relativ
schwach und dann kannst du die töten
gehst zu den trader hin und dann kriegst
du da dieses puder oder wie das heißt
raus aus dem du dir so ein op schwert
machen kannst also es hat auch 20 attack
damage also besser als jedes normale
schwert sag mal was man aus ärzten
bekommen kann
so haben wir wieder für ein upgrade
bekommen wahrscheinlich fürs laufen ja
immer noch level 2 hand als hunter level
rolle ganz viele camper und vergibt wäre
ja auch noch sicher dass mir einfach in
ruhe ich will nach hause nach hause zu
meiner stadt grün ja einfach so ist kein
ist keine stadt stadtgrün das ist
einfach eine zugehörigkeit das ist
einfach ein lebensgefühl stadtgrün
brunner so viel mist aber ich bin ein
bisschen favorisiert so dass nur der
faktor ich habe keinen bock schon wieder
gift zu bekommen man denkt ja immer okay
was wäre wenn das jetzt ein bisschen
länger anhält endlich davon sterben und
ich dann einfach alles verliere was ich
so hart erkämpft habe die letzten folgen
lang aber das wird nicht passieren leute
das wird nicht passieren und da sehe ich
schon wieder die hügel die unsere
wunderschönen stadt umgeben
auf der einen seite die gigantischen
lüge mit den riesen bäumen auf der
anderen seite das offene meer
schon als ganz cool
also ich bin echt happy wie es läuft
nicht gestorben spannende folgen so muss
das sein
vor allem nachdem
na gut bei euch sind ja schon nicht mehr
die letzten folgen wir euch waren die
letzten jahr schon alle relativ spannend
sein agent komm gib mir mal die dinge
schade dass mich in ruhe geben weil die
dinger wobei ich mir noch auf die stadt
ich glaube die teile kriegst du
eigentlich auch so schon zu häufig das
geben die wir hier so ein hatte ich auch
eingebaut
ja abzurücken die stadt ok ich freue
mich schon auf meinen baumhaus wieder
während zwei minuten oder so und dann
ist für alles erledigt 12 kartoffeln
haben wir wenn irgendwie noch know-how
drin liegt dann baue ich noch eben an
ist aber nicht so natürlich war bei mir
in die kiste
bei patrick oder 4 patrick tue ich
einfach auch war ich schreib sie mal
besten einfach das dass er sich das zeug
bei mir aus der tour nehmen kann
und ja ich weiß nicht vielleicht schaffe
ich sogar wirklich jetzt dass wir noch
fliegen können das wäre cool
wobei das eher für euch auch schon
wieder ihr ewiger ist also allerdings
kann ja schon längst fliegen so wie
heißt noch mal ist es glaube ich dass er
genau wo ich die fehler nicht weg aber
oft sogar ich glaube schon
dann ist noch genug federn drin erst mal
das ganze wertvolle oder scheinbar
wertvolle zeit zurück tun muss mir noch
eine zweite gäste machen gleich am
besten die doppel gäste zweite und das
einfach mal alles sichern so rainer
rheine rheine rheine ein
wir haben essen wir am essen viel essen
so und zu guter letzt 4 patrick hier für
den kann man nicht schiffen den amt ist
so dann holen wir uns eine gas trainer
raus eine gas trainerin voss slate sein
queenston und sechs zähler
das heißt dass hier wird erstmal dessen
blut drin meine ich ja dass hier wird
erstmals in fonds late gemacht dass mir
jetzt mal ganz kurz egal wir machen das
jetzt fertig sächsische life 5 glas glas
glas clusters fast schon fertig erinnert
ein gold mit ein paar ist heißen soll
dann her damit
so weiß nicht ob so rum ist nähe und das
riff fische live am ball und opfern
opfern opfern dann rein mit der gas
träne in den blut alters rede ich da was
rede ich denn da ich muss gar keine gas
trainerin machen
ich muss das einfach nur zusammen
kräften der blue top team braucht
natürlich noch mehr mit dem wo ist er
jetzt der topleute baukörpern körpern
zack zack zack wo ist jetzt die letzte
fehler hin
sitzen sie der 6
da ist das erste
da ist das erste schiff und wir können
fliegen
nice leute das war's von der heutigen
folge ich gefallen
mega action bis zum nächsten mal mach's
gut und tschüss nicht vergessen